[Applaudissements]
vous avez des questions alors moi j'en
ai plantes qu'un ce que vous savez moi
j'ai toujours été celui qui pose un peu
les questions débiles celui qui pose les
questions auxquelles tout le monde a
déjà la réponse et puis un jour j'ai vu
cette citation de bachelard faire de la
science c'est remettre en question les
évidences c'est génial ça c'est ça que
j'ai envie de faire et je me suis rendu
compte que oui remettre en question les
évidences ça vaut le coup vous savez par
exemple quand on dit que les chiffres ne
mentent pas ben moi je pense que si et
c'est ça la question que je pose ce soir
l'autre jour j'ai trouvé cette carte
c'est la première carte du métro de
l'ombre c'est marrant parce qu'on voit
bien les les parcs les arbres extérieur
mais c'est difficile de trouver son
itinéraire alors qu'aujourd'hui la carte
où on la connaît les métros ne vont que
dans trois directions différentes
horizontales verticales et obliques
en fait la carte ne représente pas du
tout la réalité géographique de londres
mais elle permet aux visiteurs du monde
entier de trouver leur chemin
c'est ça qui est génial c'est qu'en
changeant un peu la façon de raconter
l'histoire on rend le message beaucoup
plus universel beaucoup plus pertinent
beaucoup plus efficace le problème c'est
que la plupart des histoires ne se
termine pas aussi bien que celles du
métro à la télé par exemple
l'autre jour j'ai vu passer un graphique
sur une chaîne d'information continue
avec un camembert avec une part de 48
pour cent plus grosses que la moitié
voilà ce que ça donne avec les brèves
livré proportions
puis récemment je me suis intéressé aux
émissions de gaz à effet de serre alors
j'ai regardé depuis 1750 les émissions
annuelles de gaz de co2 en mégatonnes en
france et puis je me suis dit bon bas
pendant deux siècles s'est pas passé
grand chose et puis au xxème siècle ça
un petit peu augmenté quoi et du coup
j'étais assez surpris la semaine
dernière quand j'ai vu le passé cet
article du monde qui disait les mines
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
ont explosé au xxème siècle explosé
alors je me suis dit je vais essayer de
raconter les choses un peu autrement
déjà je vais enlever cet axe négatif
parce que bon pour représenter les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre c'est
quand même bizarre un axe négatif 1 et
puis je vais essayer de vous mais un
petit peu et alors ça y est mais oui la
même courbe sur la même période
meizu mais alors oui je vois bien la
explosion de l'émission de gaz à effet
de serre au 20e siècle
voyez deux fois les mêmes données et
pourtant deux fois de conclusion contre
complètement différente
encore une fois je me suis intéressé par
exemple au revenu moyen mensuel pardon
annuel entre la belgique la finlande la
france et le royaume uni
j'étais à peu près un peu surpris quand
même à première vue de voir à quel point
la belgique est plus riche que la
finlande
et puis j'étais un peu intrigué quand
même par ces taxes qui commence à 38
1200 euros ça veut dire quoi ça alors
j'ai pris un peu de recul il a tout à
coup c'est plus difficile de faire la
différence à tel point que si je rajoute
d'autres pays
je ne vois même pas de différence entre
ces quatre pays voyez encore une fois
trois fois les mêmes données mais trois
conclusions différentes
en fait une même donné raconte plusieurs
histoires
alors ici bon les histoires qu'on
raconte ont des conclusions différentes
mais c'est un peu anodin vous allez me
dire mais rappelez-vous yves lacoste
nous dit la géographie ça sert d'abord à
faire la guerre
moi j'ai envie de dire que les
graphiques ça sert d'abord à faire la
guerre
ce que la géographie c'est comme les
graphiques on essaye de représenter une
donnée une information alors soyons
attentifs aux messages que l'on retient
quand on voit un graphique vous
connaissez l'histoire du type qui a la
tête dans le four et les pieds dans le
congélateur
bon en moyenne ça va
le problème c'est qu'il est mort bah oui
parce qu'une moyenne
ça ne veut rien dire de la même façon
que quand on dit qu'au moyen-âge
l'espérance de vie était de 18 ans les
gens mouraient en moyenne à 18 ans mais
n'aurait pas soudainement foudroyé à
l'âge adulte il mourrait à la naissance
ou bien à 50 ans parce qu'une moyenne
ça ne veut rien dire un autre exemple en
france le salaire moyen mensuel c'est
3000 euros c'est beaucoup entre mille
euros pour moi mais en fait une personne
sur deux en france gagne moins de 1800
euros
une personne sur deux gagnent moins de
1800 euros alors que la moyenne est à
3000 euros par ce pas parce que parmi
ceux qui gagnent plus il y en a qui
gagnent énormément plus et ça gonfle que
la moyenne ce qu'une moyenne
ça ne veut rien dire l'autre jour je me
suis demandé comment est ce que je
serais pour pour réduire le taux de
chômage
d'abord je
dit je vais essayer traverser la rue et
puis je me suis dit mais non il ya plus
simple je vais changer la définition du
chômage
je vais dire tiens que toutes les
personnes en situation d'invalidité
professionnels ce ne sont plus des
chômeurs et puis voilà 5% de chômage qui
s'est facilement un peu too much vous
allez me dire et pourtant c'est
exactement ce qu'a fait tony blair en
2000 en changeant la définition du
chômage
il a passé le taux de chômage au
royaume-uni sous des seuils records mais
là encore il n'avait fait qu'appliquer
l'adage de churchill
je ne crois aux statistiques que lorsque
je les ai moi même fabriqué forcément en
choisissant sa définition il choisit
l'histoire qu'il veut nous raconter
c'est une histoire à laquelle nous avons
envie de croire parce que 5% de chômage
c'est beau mais l'histoire que nous
avons retenu mais pas celle que nous
croyons avoir comprises quand j'étais
petit je croyais que c'étaient les
cigognes qui a porté les bébés et puis
j'ai grandi et puis je me suis rendu
compte que ce n'était pas le cas mais
par curiosité j'ai quand même regardé
dans des pays le nombre de bébés en
fonction du nombre de cigognes et j'ai
quand même été un peu surpris parce
qu'en turquie par exemple il ya beaucoup
de cigognes en turquie il ya beaucoup de
bébés aussi
alors qu'en suisse il ya très peu de
cigognes amende bébé vous et oui en fait
les données sont corrélés mais une
corrélation aussi grande qu'elle soit
n'indique jamais un lien de cause à
effet direct
la langue corrélation ça veut dire quoi
par revenons par exemple dans les années
à cette époque les premières études ont
mis en évidence une corrélation entre le
fait de fumer et les risques d'avoir un
cancer du poumon
à l'époque trois écoles se sont
distingués ceux qui disaient que fumer
cause le cancer du poumon ceux qui
disaient qu avoir un cancer donne envie
de fumer et ceux qui disaient que ce
serait en fait un gène qui causerait à
la fois l'envié de fumer et à la fois
augmenterait les risques d'avoir un
cancer du poumon
les lobby du tabac ont vraiment avancé
l'hypothèse de ce gène en disant que les
porteurs du gène ne pourrait rien y
faire il aurait plus envie de fumer et
ils auraient plus de risques d'avoir un
cancer du poumon
alors aujourd'hui certaines hypothèses
nous semble absurde bien sûr mais à
l'époque la question est légitime et en
tout cas ce n'est pas la corrélation qui
permet de conclure parce qu'une
corrélation ça ne prouve rien alors
comment faire comment passer de la
corrélation à la causalité
prenons un autre exemple comment passer
par exemple de la corrélation entre le
fait de porter gaumont sa ceinture de
sécurité et les risques de mort dans un
accident il ya bien une corrélation mais
imaginons que toutes les personnes qui
n'attache pas leur ceinture soit en fait
des conducteurs négligent en fait ces
conducteurs là ce serait leur attitude
qui ferait que à la fois ils n'auraient
pas de ceinture et à la fois quand ils
ont un accident c'est beaucoup plus
grave donc ils sont beaucoup plus en
danger de mort ça expliquerait la
corrélation mais du coup ça montrerait
que la ceinture n'a rien à voir dans la
sphère alors comment faire
imaginons cette expérience très simple
peu comme un crash test on prendrait des
mannequins on leur ferait tous suivre la
même route avec le même style de
conduite du même environnement etc ont
simulé un accident à la fin de la route
mais à la moitié d'entre eux on
attacherait leur ceinture et par l'autre
et bien sûr à qui on a attaché leur
ceinture subiront des dommages beaucoup
moins grave lors de l'accident
sauf que là comme on a maîtrisé tout le
reste de l'environnement et on a bien
montré que c'est la ceinture qui les a
sauvés
revenant dans cette histoire de
cigarettes
la corrélation ne prouve rien mais les
médecins ont étudié les effets de la
cigarette sur la santé
ils ont bien réussi à montrer que ingéré
de la fumer provoque des mutations des
cellules pulmonaires des mutations
caractéristiques d'un cancer
ils ont bien réussi à montrer que fumer
provoque le cancer du poumon 39e chose
on dit qu'une image vaut mille mots
il ya un chiffre vaut mille histoires
différentes avec chacune une morale avec
une même donné en représentant les
choses par un graphique on peut
transmettre deux messages opposé une
moyenne par contre ça ne veut rien dire
et quant à la corrélation ça ne prouve
jamais un lien de cause à effet
heureusement bien qu'une image vaut
mille mots et que c'est à nous pendant
qu'un chiffre vaut mille histoires et
c'est à nous de savoir quelle histoire
nous devons croire n'attendons pas que
d'autres le fassent pour nous réveillons
nous faisons un choix et n'oublions pas
que pour faire ce choix
nous avons le droit de questionner
l'évidence merci
[Applaudissements]